>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Marie Arana: Good evening.
>> Good evening.
>> Marie Arana: Good
evening, ladies and gentlemen.
And welcome, welcome to the
Library of Congress' celebration
of Women's History Month.
It's so nice to have
you here with us.
It's such a pleasure.
And to our live stream
audience out there,
welcome to the Library
of Congress,
the beautiful Jefferson
building,
the historic Coolidge
Auditorium,
in which we're putting
on this program.
Welcome to all of you.
My name is Marie
Arana, and I am a writer
and the literary director of
the National Book Festival,
if you ever come out for
that, and the Literary Adviser
to the Library of Congress.
And I'm so sorry to say,
Carla Hayden, Dr. Hayden,
our Librarian of Congress,
the first woman Librarian
of Congress in the history of
the United States of America--
[ Applause ]
-- is home with a strep throat.
So you're going to have to deal
with me as the interviewer.
But she sends all her best
and a big greeting to you
on Women's History Month.
So here's the big question
that we're posing today.
Now, you heard the names, right,
of John Glenn and Alan Shepard
and Neil Armstrong, but
what about Katherine Johnson
and Mary Jackson and Dorothy
Vaughan and Kathryn Peddrew
and Sue Wilder and Eunice
Smith and Barbara Holly?
We're here to throw a very
bright light on a wonderful book
and a wonderful movie.
Margot Lee Shetterly's book
Hidden Figures is the remarkable
story of three pioneering
African-American women at NASA.
And as it happens, that story
sits smack dab in the middle
of some of the most defining
moments of the 20th century,
the Cold War, the Space Race,
the Civil Rights Movement,
and the ongoing quest
for gender equality.
Though they did the same work
as whites hired at the time,
these women were kept apart,
not only in gender-segregated
offices,
but in racially-segregated
in NASA's Langley campus.
And despite the hardships
of working
under strict Jim Crow laws,
they went on to make significant
contributions to aeronautics,
astronautics, and
America's victory
over the USSR in the Space Race.
By now, Hidden Figures has been
published as a young adult book
and as a children's
book so that a universe
of young girls can be inspired
by this story of grit, grace,
perseverance and excellence.
And now I'm told
there's even a doll
of Katherine Johnson,
which is amazing.
I'll have to get that
for my grandchildren.
And to let you know that Hidden
Figures will actually be on sale
after this program, and Margot
will be signing her books.
So just last week, Margot Lee
Shetterly published a wonderful
essay for Women's History Month
in the Library of
Congress Magazine.
Now, if you don't know
this magazine, you should.
On the back page is
this wonderful essay
in which Margot says, when I was
growing up in Hampton, Virginia,
the face of science
was brown like mine.
My dad was a NASA lifer,
a career Langley
research premier--
sorry, a career Langley
research scientist
who became an internationally
respected climate expert.
Five of my father's seven
siblings were engineers,
or technologists.
My father's best friend was
an aeronautical engineer.
Our next door neighbor
was a physics professor.
There were mathematicians in
our church, sonic boom experts
in my mother's sorority,
and electrical engineers
in my parents' college
alumni association.
And then she writes in
big capital letters,
why don't we know more
about these people?
Well, let's you don't know
enough about the person asking
that question, let me tell
you a little bit about her.
Margot Lee Shetterly was
born in Hampton, Virginia.
Her father was a
research scientist,
as I've said, at NASA.
Her mother was an
English professor
at the historically
black Hampton University.
She graduated from
the University
of Virginia's McIntire
School of Commerce.
After college, she moved to New
York and worked several years
in investment banking; J.P.
Morgan, and then Merrill Lynch.
She began researching and
writing Hidden Figures in 2010.
In 2014, she sold the book and
film rights to William Morrow,
a division of HarperCollins.
And even as a proposal, not even
a manuscript, it was published,
it was auctioned, sorry, by the
other guest we're going to hear
from tonight, Donna
Gigliotti of Levantine Films.
Margot is also the founder of
the Human Computer Project,
an effort to recover the
names and accomplishments
of all the women who worked
as computers, mathematicians,
scientists, and engineers at
NASA, and its predecessor, NACA,
from the 1930s through
the 1980s.
Who was Donna Gigliotti?
The woman who brought
us the Hidden Figures
on the big screen?
Donna is an American
film producer.
She is best known for producing
the Academy Award-winning film
Shakespeare in Love.
She also produced the Academy
Award-winning films Silver
Linings Playbook and The Reader.
She began her career as an
assistant to Martin Scorsese
on the film Raging Bull.
During the 90s, she worked
as an executive producer
on several films, including
Emma, Talk of Angels,
and Devil in a Blue Dress.
Currently, Donna serves as the
President of Tempesta Films.
She developed and
produced Hidden Figures,
the film which stars, as
you all know, Taraji Henson,
Octavia Spencer, Janelle
Monae, and Kevin Costner.
The film won dozens,
literally dozens of awards,
and was nominated by the 2017
Academy Awards for best picture,
best screenplay, and
best supporting actress.
To remind you of the film,
my colleague Solomon Haley
Salasy [phonetic] at the Library
of Congress, has
produced a short video,
and we'd like to
share it with you now.
It's not meant to
be biographical
or documentary in any way.
It's a tribute to the
African-American women who,
despite great odds, played
a groundbreaking role
in American scientific progress.
Solomon?
[ Music ]
>> I need a mathematician
that can look beyond a number.
>> I never knew there were
women working on engineering
and aeronautics at NASA
during the Space Race.
>> They were all these smart
and brilliant-minded
women who were hidden.
>> But they had really
next-level jobs.
>> Shall we launch this rocket?
>> We're putting a human on
top of a missile shooting him
into space, and it's
never been done before.
>> Do you have the
numbers that can get us
up there before Russia?
>> These women changed the game.
>> It's wonderful to
play a strong woman.
But they have vulnerabilities.
>> You've been gone
for 300 hours.
>> Was mama gone
for 12 1/2 days?
>> No, but it felt like it.
>> It felt like it to me too.
>> These ordinary women
did extraordinary things.
>> It's crunch time.
In 14 days, astronauts
will be here for training.
Everything we do can matter to
their wives, to their children.
I believe it's going to matter
to the whole damn country.
>> Think about what that
struggle must have felt like.
>> There is no protocol
for women attending.
>> It's the protocol for
a man circling the Earth.
>> Hidden Figures is about
how black and white men
and women put a man in space.
That's empowering.
>> There's a real
fireball outside.
It's getting a little
hot in here.
>> We're in the fight
of our lives, people.
[ Applause ]
>> Marie Arana: Pretty
wonderful.
Now, ladies and gentlemen,
I'd like you
to welcome the award-winning
wonderful writer,
Margot Lee Shetterly, and the
award-winning marvelous film
producer, Donna Gigliotti.
[ Applause ]
So glad to have you here
at the Library of Congress.
Thank you for making the
trip, Donna and Margot.
Wonderful to have you here.
I want to start with we
were talking backstage
about exactly how this
movie came to be made.
And I, in fact, had in
my notes that it had come
after you had read
the manuscript.
But no, that's not the story.
Tell us the story,
Margot and Donna.
>> Margot Shetterly:
Well, I started working
on Hidden Figures, what would
become Hidden Figures, in 2010,
and started doing research.
I grew up in Hampton, Virginia.
I knew Katherine Johnson
from the time I was a child.
My dad worked at NASA.
And anyway, started
working on the book.
2013, started, had written a
book proposal, found an agent
who then sold it
to HarperCollins
to be published in 2014.
And really kind of
unbeknownst to me.
It wasn't very clear.
And maybe we can talk about
how it actually happened.
It's still kind of a mystery.
My book proposal
ended up in the hands
of someone named
Donna Gigliotti.
And I, you know, remember
being in Hampton, Virginia,
and getting a phone
call, and I pulled
over into the parking
lot of the Food Lion.
If anybody here is
from Virginia.
>> Donna Gigliotti: It's my
favorite part of the story,
that she pulled into
the Food Lion.
That specificity tells
you she's an author.
>> Margot Shetterly: Yeah, so,
you know, my Virginia people,
I pulled into the Food
Lion, and, you know,
Donna introduced
herself, and she said,
on that first phone call,
we're going to make
a movie of this book.
And I said, well, you
know, it's not a book yet,
which didn't exist at the time.
It didn't exist.
It was a book proposal.
And yet this very
intrepid multiply awarded,
gifted filmmaker had a vision
for this 55-page book proposal.
And that was in-- that
was four years ago.
It was this time four years ago.
>> Donna Gigliotti: And the
part she's leaving out about
that story is that I
said to her, when she was
in the parking lot of the Food
Lion, and we're going to go
to the Oscars together.
[ Applause ]
>> Margot Shetterly:
On the first phone call
in the parking lot
of the Food Lion.
That is what happened.
>> Marie Arana: Incredible.
>> Margot Shetterly:
It was amazing.
>> Donna Gigliotti: But,
you know, it sounds, I mean,
it's nice that it sounds like
fairyland and all of that,
but the truth was that
Margot, she was onto something
with that book proposal
that I could feel.
I knew it.
It was in the Zeitgeist.
And it was about women
not getting their due,
African-American women
not getting their due.
It was about math.
It was about space.
It was a confluence of
things that really caused--
I never doubted that
it would be successful,
because you could feel
it in the Zeitgeist,
and she tapped into it.
>> Marie Arana: And this was
even before the whole mania
of Code Girls.
And that didn't actually happen
until the following year.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
No, it didn't,
because what I remember
very clearly is shortly
after optioning the proposal,
book proposal, Google came out
and adamant, they
finally came clean
on what the composition was
of their workforce, right?
And it was astonishing
because it was largely male
and largely white.
And I thought, okay, now,
I know that this is right,
it's in the Zeitgeist.
So it was that coupled
with maybe eight
or nine months later,
Oscar Sir White coming out.
And, therefore, the
confluence was,
it was undeniable, actually.
>> Marie Arana: Yeah, yeah,
wonderful, wonderful story.
I want to back way up and ask
you about, for the young people
in the audience who are
watching, and out there
in my stream, what was it about
your youth that brought you
to this place, or that made
you what you are today, Margot?
What was it about your youth
that actually was the drive?
Where was it?
Or, you know, how did it happen
that you are who you are today,
given the child that
you were then?
>> Margot Shetterly: You know, a
lot of it really does have to do
with my parents and the
community that I grew up in
and the people I grew up around.
As I mentioned, my
father worked at NASA,
my mother was an English
professor at Hampton University,
and there was this expectation.
I mean, you know, I think
I've finally redeemed myself
with my dad.
He wanted me to become
an engineer.
I didn't. So I think I've
kind of finally done enough
to redeem myself with that.
But from the time I was little,
we would go and see my mom
at work over at Hampton
University.
We would see James Baldwin, you
know, and Maya Angelou, and,
you know, all of these
amazing writers and performers
who would come to
Hampton University.
We would go over to NASA and
get, you know, computer paper,
like this, you know, I'm so
dating me in such a huge way,
like you would not believe the
kind of huge paper that would,
you know, get produced
for these calculations
that they were doing
back in the 70s.
And so the thing
that was so wonderful
about that was being exposed at
a very young age to this entire,
very wide spectrum of
different kinds of people,
different backgrounds, women
who were working at NASA,
who were professors
like my mother.
And so there was never this
idea that there was anything
that was really off limits.
And I think having that
exposure from a young age.
And I think particularly,
you know, really to see a lot
of women working and doing
these jobs as scientists,
you kind of take it for granted.
And when that is the floor, it
makes it very easy to then say,
well, you know, well, I
don't want to do that,
I want to do something
else, which, you know,
I wanted to work on Wall Street.
That seem like the
new frontier to me.
But having had that very, just
very nurturing, both in terms
of my parents, but also the
community around us, you know,
this is really a love letter in
so many ways to that childhood.
>> Marie Arana: Your parents,
absolutely, absolutely.
How about you, Donna, how
did you get to where you are?
>> Donna Gigliotti: It's
a very similar story.
I grew up in Upstate New
York, in a little tiny town.
And essentially, it was a
tremendous amount of support
from my family and
the community.
But it really was my mother.
I'm old. I was born in 1954.
And it was my mother always
saying you can do whatever it is
that you want to do.
You know, she was
of a slightly--
that earlier generation, maybe
she was a little frustrated
and put that all onto me.
I always tell the story
that this is true.
I was 18 years old before I
realized I was not the prettiest
or the smartest girl
in the world.
Because she told me
that the entire time.
It was astonishing to me,
astonishing that that
was not the case.
[ Laughter ]
So mom.
>> Marie Arana: Yeah, mom.
Oh, moms are great.
Moms, Women's History
Month, I mean,
let's hear it for the moms.
[ Applause ]
Paying tribute to them.
And how was it, Margot, that you
actually came upon this subject?
I mean, you've said, and you've
written in this magazine,
and you've said many
times that it was
that culture that
you grew up in.
But actually, stumbling
on this actual story,
how did that happen?
>> Margot Shetterly: Well,
the thing that's really great
about it is this story
has very much to do
with the most important
men in my life.
So my husband and I had
gone home Christmas 2010
to visit my parents.
And we ran into a woman who
was somebody that we had known
from church, you
know, growing up,
she was my Sunday
school teacher,
and my dad just started
talking about her.
She's since died.
She was 96, I think, but
had worked her whole career
as a computer in the west
area, computing group.
And I didn't quite know it.
You know, there's so
many things that you know
as a kid, or you hear as a kid.
You kind of just, you
know, you know, whatever,
it's not important
to me, whatever.
Anyway, and so it turned
into this entire conversation
with me kind of listening,
right, between my dad
and my husband, and my husband
listening to this, like,
oh my gosh, I can't believe
this, like I can't believe.
What? I've never heard
this story before.
And I had heard this story.
I had known these women, but
never really took the time
to think, well, jeez, why
was Katherine Johnson there?
Why were there black
women mathematicians
at NASA in the 1950s?
Why was my, you know,
now 96-year-old Sunday school
teacher, where did, you know,
how did this all happen?
And it was really a moment
for me of seeing something
with fresh eyes, something
that we had really taken
for granted growing
up in the Hampton.
Because they were just normal.
They got up, they went to work,
they went to the PTA meetings,
we saw them in the Food Lion.
It was normal, you know?
And yet it was a totally
extraordinary thing
that they had known, an
extraordinary history
that had happened there.
And that was really
the beginning of it.
My husband is a writer, and he
was like, this is a great book.
And then that was really
the beginning of it.
>> Marie Arana: Let's
hear it for good husbands.
[ Applause ]
So, but you knew
Katherine Johnson.
And what was she like?
I mean, the version that we all
have is the version, of course,
that's in your book,
which is very vivid.
And then this vision of a
young Katherine Johnson.
You must have known her, of
course, when she was older.
>> Margot Shetterly: I
remember her when I was a kid.
It was right around the time
that she had retired from NASA.
But she was one of
these extremely active
in the community, she was the
president of the local chapter
of the sorority, she
was very, you know,
just an impeccable person, tall
with a pant suit, and, you know,
not the kind of person
that you wanted to kind of,
you wanted to be on
the right side of.
And she's funny and gracious,
but very serious, you know?
And as a kid, you know the
people who are very serious,
and you do not jump around
and play around and whatever.
But she was part of this
community, you know?
And during the course of
the research for the book,
I realized just how much
had been written about her.
I mean, the first
article that I found
on Katherine Johnson
was published
in I think late 1959,
early 1960.
So two years before
John Glenn's flight.
And she's had this sort
of, you know, mythology,
grow up around her
in Hampton, Virginia.
But, I mean, she was an
active part of the community.
You know, she was part
of a group of people.
So even as people knew
about the achievements,
she was still part
of a group, you know?
She did not stand
apart from the rest
of the people there
in the community.
>> Marie Arana: Do you think
that she realized what part
in history she had played?
I mean, that she was aware of
the importance of being a woman,
being an African-American
woman, being a scientist,
and being at that
place in time in NASA,
when this was going down,
it was a very big deal.
You know, the Space
Race was huge.
And Yuri Gagarin had
gotten up into space,
and we needed to get up there.
And did she seem like the
sort of person who was aware
of her importance, or was
she sort of dismissive
and not necessarily
strutting it?
>> Margot Shetterly:
Well, I think, I think she
and the other women were
very aware of their roles
in the mission and
what they had done
and what they had contributed
to the mission and to the work.
I think the awareness of history
is something that takes time.
And I think that's something
that now, not just she,
but all of these other
women, and, you know,
the women of Code Girls,
for example, and, I mean,
there are so many stories about
women having done these things.
So history is recognizing it.
But if you talk to these women,
I mean, Katherine Johnson,
you know, I was just
doing my job.
>> Donna Gigliotti: Exactly.
Very modest, in a lot
of ways, about her role
and the entire process.
>> Marie Arana: Yeah, how was
she at the Academy Awards?
Because she is 100
years old now.
>> Donna Gigliotti: Yes,
this year, she turns 100.
She was-- well, we
think she was excited
because her daughters told
us that she was excited.
But he wasn't having
any of it, you know?
There was no-- it was like, yep,
I'm going to the
Academy Awards, yep.
She actually did have
that dress made for her,
and she went through fittings.
But, you know, initially, I
think she was a little befuddled
by all of the hoopla
around the movie.
And I remember when Taraji went
down to meet her, Taraji was--
I don't know if you
watch Empire,
but Taraji plays a
character called Cookie,
and Taraji was still in, she was
in full Cookie mode, you know?
She had the nails and the hat,
and Taraji's got
a lot of energy.
And I think Katherine Johnson
did not know what to do
with Taraji P. Henson
in that room.
But ultimately, like they found
the place, and it was so--
Taraji, if she were here,
would tell you how important
that meeting was, because she
got to actually understand,
and she listened a lot to
like tapes of Katherine
so she could get
the syntax right.
There was a lot of research
that went into that performance.
But Katherine, I think,
was a little like, whoa,
what's happening here?
[ Laughter ]
>> Marie Arana: I
get this picture of,
I mean, picture this.
You've got a writer who
has sold, in proposal,
which is rare, I've never
heard of such a thing,
this probably happens
more than I realize.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
But not a lot.
>> Marie Arana: Not a lot.
From a proposal-- so you
haven't written the book.
You have, with great hope,
sort of put this proposal
forward for publication.
It has been bought.
It has also been
bought for a film.
And the film is turning while
you're writing the actual book.
Imagine that.
And I'm imagining you making the
film on the basis of, I mean,
it was a 50-page proposal.
This was not a small, this
was not five pages, right?
It was a substantial proposal.
So you had a lot to work with.
But the picture I have
of you is, you know,
these two women scrambling
to produce it.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
We have no idea.
Essentially, it went like this.
Margot, did you finish
the book yet?
Have you finished the book?
The [inaudible] coming up.
The movie's going to be out.
Have you finished the book?
>> Margot Shetterly: You know?
I'm like, oh my gosh, I've
got to finish the book.
I mean, all of a sudden, it
was like, there's the script.
Wait a minute, wait a
minute, wait a minute.
Wait, wait.
I'm looking at the book,
I'm like, you know,
because everything has to
be, you know, I'm like, well,
I'm writing this book, and it
takes place from 1943 to 1969
with an epilogue that
goes into the 70s.
How come this thing
is only going to be
in 1962, this movie, you know?
Which ultimately was
obviously a very good decision.
But it was so interesting
for me to do something
that I have never done before,
and to go through this other,
simultaneously, another
experience based on this thing
that I had never done
before and do that too.
And it was, it was--
I learned so much.
>> Donna Gigliotti: And
the great thing is, though,
that we also came
out of it as friends,
even though I was torturing
her every day and saying.
>> Margot Shetterly:
I got tortured.
>> Donna Gigliotti: Margot,
did you finish the book?
And we really did come out as
great friends, which is a gift.
And she looks very
pretty walking
that red carpet at the Oscars.
>> Margot Shetterly: That
was, that was a lot of fun.
It was an incredible experience.
But from the very
beginning, you know,
the thing that I really
appreciated about the movie is,
you know, Donna came in with
this vision of this, you know,
this story and these women, and
the importance of these women,
and then you really made it your
mission to get the best people,
and the people who
understood what it meant
and what it could mean
to girls, to women,
to African-Americans,
to scientists.
You know, I was-- it was so
amazing to go in in this,
you know, in the Food
Lion parking lot,
and to come out at the Oscars.
[ Applause ]
And to-- but to come, to
come away with the experience
of having worked with
such talented, committed,
interesting people
along the way.
It was fantastic.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
You know, it was--
but when I say that there was
a kind of kismet going on,
what she's talking
about, one of the people
that was absolutely integral
to the whole process
was Pharrell Williams.
And it happened almost
by accident.
His partner, his business
partner is a woman called Mimi
Valdes, and she came in
to see me just in general,
and she said, what kind of
things are you working on?
And I said, oh, you know,
I'm developing this script.
It's called the Hidden Figures.
And I told her what
it was about.
And she was silent
throughout the entire thing.
And at the end of the,
end of my pitch, she said,
Pharrell will do anything
to be a part of that.
And I said, why is that?
And she said, well, you know,
he grew up in Hampton, Virginia.
Who knew? Very involved
in the STEM initiative.
Great. And he's obsessed
with space.
I go, okay, that's good.
>> Marie Arana: Check,
check, check.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
Check, check, check.
But, you know, in Hollywood,
people say stuff like that,
like Pharrell will do
anything to be a part of it.
And you go, mhmm, yeah, great.
The next day, my assistant
comes running into my office,
and he's shaking, and he's like,
Pharrell Williams
is on the phone.
And it's true.
Pharrell Williams gets on the
phone the next day, he said,
because he's southern, he called
me Miss Donna, and he said,
Miss Donna, I will do anything
to be a part of this project.
And I was like, okay,
yeah, good, good, good.
And he said, I'm coming into
New York in another week.
Can we meet?
I said, sure, no problem.
A week passes, I go to meet
him, and he said, I mean,
there's so many elements of this
movie that are important to me.
What can I do on it?
Well, you think to yourself, you
know, you're Pharrell Williams,
I think you could do the music.
[ Laughter ]
So he said-- I said, I think
you could do the music.
So he said, oh, good,
good, good,
because I've been
working on some stuff.
Margot hasn't finished the
book, I don't have any actors,
and Pharrell has
written the music.
So he said, here,
I'll play it for you.
And I thought, really?
Okay. So he put his iPod into
the speakers, and I listen.
I went, that's great.
Listen again, another
song, great.
This is really, this
is the best story.
That's why I'm telling it.
Because he got to
another song, and he said,
I only have the instrumentals.
And I was like, all right,
dude, it's fine, you know?
And he said, no, no, no,
it's really, really good.
He said, I'll just have
to sing it for you.
I kid you not.
Because if he was
sitting next to me,
he would recount this
exactly as I did.
He sat on the couch,
the Crosby Street Hotel,
and he sang the song to me.
I thought, you got the job.
That's fine.
You know, having
people like that,
Octavia Spencer,
she walks on water.
Not only is she a magnificent
actor, but she was so--
the first time she came
in to see me, he said,
I don't know what
part I want to play.
Do I want to play Dorothy
or do I want to play Mary?
I said, I don't know, which
one do you want to play?
I mean, having that, what
Margot was talking about,
that was a very special group
of people that we had around us.
>> Marie Arana: It
sounds absolutely magical.
And, of course, it
ended up being, what,
nominated for Best Screenplay.
So something was going on in the
actual writing process as well.
Tell us about the research for
the book and how you did that,
because you were talking
about lives and interviews
and papers and all of that.
>> Margot Shetterly: It
was really, you know,
it was so interesting, the
sort of chain of knowledge.
You know, one fact
would lead to the other.
So the first interview,
of course,
was with Katherine Johnson.
And Katherine Johnson
mentioned a number of people
in that first interview.
One of them was Dorothy Vaughan,
whose name I had never heard of.
Dorothy Vaughan actually left,
retired shortly before
my father started,
or shortly after my father
started working there.
And she mentioned Mary Jackson,
who actually I did know,
because she had worked
with my father
in the early part of his career.
She mentioned Christine
Darden, who was in the book,
who was not in the movie,
because she went to school with,
and is the next generation
of engineers.
So, you know, every time I
got a clue, I would just have
to go and, you know, off and
kind of like an archaeologist,
sort of excavate
the information.
Because the information
was there.
It was really there.
But it had never been
collated into one place.
So a lot of work in
the National Archives,
the NASA History Office, and the
NASA Langley History Office were
particularly useful.
Interviews with Katherine
Johnson and her children
and Dorothy Vaughan's
children, and, you know,
Mary Jackson's colleagues,
I mean,
there was so much information.
And then really this wonderful
opportunity to go into the math
and the science and the
engineering itself, and spending
so much time with
the actual reports
that these women worked on.
And it was such an incredible--
it was like being in a
time machine, you know?
Every morning I would get up,
and I'd have my research tasks,
and it was like I
jumped in a time machine,
and I went back to 1943.
And sometimes it
was about airplanes,
because they were working on
airplanes before spaceships.
Sometimes it was about the Civil
Rights legislation that opens
up public schools and public
accommodations and, you know,
all of these other things.
Sometimes it was about
the role of women
and how women made
breakthroughs in World War II
and what happened after that.
So I got this incredible history
lesson during the research.
And it was really like
the people came back
to life, you know?
I wish I had known
Dorothy Vaughan, you know?
That's like one of my
great regrets for this.
But I feel as if I have
gotten to know her,
just from having spent so
much time with the documents
and the people who knew her.
So it was overwhelming.
The hardest part was really
wrestling this information
into a narrative, and doing it
in a way was really important
that the people lead the story,
that it wasn't just, you know,
okay, 1963, John, you know,
Glenn did this, and, you know,
that really it was always about
these women, that's a story
that we knew, we know this
story of space, but they got
to be the protagonists.
And that it was always
a human story,
that it always connected
back to them as people
and not just the sort
of historical facts.
>> Marie Arana: Right.
My impression is that a lot
of women went into science,
correct me if I'm
wrong, went into science,
really during the war when
the, you know, the college
and universities were-- the
men had all gone to war.
And so more women went in, more
people of different races went
in to those educational spots
that were suddenly open.
Is this what happened in the
process of these women's lives,
that they were given
opportunities by virtue
of the circumstance of the war?
>> Margot Shetterly: It was.
World War II, I mean, World
War II transformed our country
in so many different ways.
Legally, there was
an executive order
that forbade discrimination
in the civil service.
And that was the thing that
opened the door for these women.
But then just supply and demand.
I mean, the men were
off in the war,
and these women were
really good at math.
I mean, they were math
teachers, most of them,
before they came there.
But they were exceptionally
talented mathematicians.
So once that door opened,
those women took a seat,
and that changed our country.
>> Marie Arana: There is, of
course, the wonderful scene
in the movie where that
bathroom sign comes down, and,
you know, the outrage is clear.
It actually, as I
understand it from the book,
Katherine Johnson was going to--
she was not doing
the 800 meter hike.
She was actually using
the bathroom right there.
And nobody dared to say anything
because she was such a proud,
elegant, obviously nobody was
going to say anything to her.
So there are differences
in the movie,
and in the reality
and the movie.
Tell us about your decisions
to sort of conflate some people
into one, for instance, and
change the time a little bit,
and those decisions, which
had to be made obviously.
>> Donna Gigliotti: They
do, because, you know,
movies fall into
three-act structures,
and you need a dramatic arc.
And so, I mean, it is true
that the bathrooms
had been desegregated
at NASA before the time period.
>> Marie Arana: Everybody
knew that it happened, yeah.
>> Donna Gigliotti: Margot's
father was very clear about this
when we toured the facility, and
he said, Donna, that's not true.
But I said, it's the movies.
I mean, that is-- I
take full responsibility
for putting Katherine
Johnson in mission control
at the end of the movie.
That's not true.
There was no woman in
mission control for--
it had to have been another 10
years before there was a woman
in that room.
But you would have felt--
what would you have done?
I mean, you have to
have a moment of triumph
for the character on some level.
So you kind of have
to take those leaps,
which is why you will notice it
says inspired by a true story
on the front of the film.
It doesn't say based on.
It says inspired by.
And that's there for a
reason, because we did have
to take those kind
of dramatic jumps.
>> Marie Arana: So
emotionally true, you would say?
>> Donna Gigliotti: Yes.
>> Marie Arana: Right.
Let's talk about the
culture that has--
the culture at NASA
has obviously changed.
We have had now African-American
astronauts.
>> Margot Shetterly:
African-American administrator,
deputy administrator,
female deputy administrator,
chief scientist.
>> Marie Arana: Right.
Yeah, right.
How was that progress?
How did that happen?
And was it tough going,
or did the doors just
fling open at some point?
How did that actually progress?
>> Margot Shetterly: Well, you
know, the interesting thing
about NASA is that as
a government entity,
it was always more progressive
than the aircraft industries
and the contractors
and things like that.
And I think, you know,
that's one of the reasons
why I was able to grow up
and see this critical mass
of women of all backgrounds
who were working there, of
my father working there.
It was a more open
work environment.
You know, the doors
were, you know,
more open to different
kinds of people.
And so I think in that
sense, NASA, you know,
the DNA was sort of
set way back then.
And I do think that there
is a direct relationship
between what those
women were able to do
and their accomplishments
and the fact
that this agency
eventually had, you know,
an African-American
administrator,
several female center Chiefs,
African-American
center directors.
So, you know, I think
there's, you know, when we talk
about sort of the implications,
the larger implications
for this story and for
organizations today,
I do think that when you put
that into the organizational DNA
and you make it possible
for talented people,
regardless of who
they are, to go as far
as their talent will
take them and contribute
to the organization, then you
get the people at the top who,
you know, who are also
able to do that, you know?
And if you want to
have, you know, CEOs,
C-suite level people, who, you
know, are diverse and female
and look like America,
well, you've got to start
with that base level
DNA of the organization.
I think that's one
of the story's important
takeaways from this story.
>> Marie Arana: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
And I'm sure that
you've heard from people
out there how your book
and your story and the film
and the whole sort of
composite has inspired people,
or young women, girls,
to go into STEM courses,
which is so important
in this country today.
What sort of reaction
have you been getting
on that front from educators?
>> Donna Gigliotti:
Well, we joke about this,
that Hidden Figures, those are
the magic words to use today,
I had something to do
with Hidden Figures.
But, you know, I
mean, it's almost more
than the book and the film.
It feels like a movement
on some level.
And the thing that's exciting
for the both of us, I think,
is that the only-- I
think this is true,
that one of the most
important ways
that you can shift the culture
is to portray women or people
of color in a way that
is surprising and new,
and what is engendered from
that is a new way of thinking.
And that's what we've seen
in terms of Black Girls Code,
and it goes on and on and on.
What were you just telling
me at dinner about India?
>> Margot Shetterly:
Well, just, you know,
this thing that Hidden
Figure has become a term.
You know, so I have this
Google alert that sets up for,
you know, Hidden Figures,
and I would just pick
up all the articles that
mention Hidden Figures.
And it's everything
from, you know,
the local association
wherever in Virginia is going
to be screening the movie to
like this event, you know,
will turn up or whatever.
But like the Hidden Figures of
India's agriculture industry
or something, you know?
I mean, but this, this is
something that people, I mean,
talking about the
movement, people are like,
I knew there was more
than I was being told.
I knew there were people
out there doing these different
things, and I didn't know how
to find them, I didn't
know where to find them.
And I think that's the energy
that they're like, oh my gosh,
I see the success, and now
I have a completer idea
of the world and what I
might do in the world.
And the girls, you know, I
don't know if I told you this,
I got this tweet, this was last
year, and this woman, a mom,
she was like, listen, I
have, you know, a daughter,
she's nine years old,
she's in the fourth grade,
and she is very math phobic,
and she tried so hard to get her
to just, you know, because it
wasn't that she was quite bad
at math, she had a phobia,
you know, she had a block,
and she saw the movie, and the
mom said that her daughter said
to her on the eve of a math
test, the numbers are going
into my head just
like Dorothy Vaughan.
[ Laughter ]
And you say to yourself, wow,
you know, that is humbling
to hear a story like that.
>> Marie Arana: That's
wonderful.
That is really wonderful.
We want to open it up to
questions from the audience.
We have two mics that are going
to roam, and anybody who would
like to-- and we
welcome your questions.
I would just ask that you please
stand when you ask a question,
and that you hold the
mic, speak into the mic
so that we can actually
hear you and record you.
Any questions out there?
Over here?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay, wait for the mic, please.
Thank you.
>> Thank you for
wonderful presentation.
Very inspiring for all of us,
women, and for younger people.
I just want to go further
and say about your idea
about Hidden Figures
and you wrote
about in mathematics,
and NASA, and so on.
Why not to go further?
A lot of hidden figures in
industries and other places,
sometimes women really
don't have a voice,
maybe to go further, is just
an invitation, is just an idea,
to discuss more about woman's
role in different other places,
other industries, and so on.
Thank you.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
Well, that's a good idea.
I mean, maybe you
should consider
like Volume 2, Volume 3.
Thank you very much for that.
>> Marie Arana: I
see you in the back.
Other question?
Thank you.
Right here?
Over there.
Sorry.
>> I'm just wondering in the
course of writing the book
and gathering all the research,
what personal transformation did
you undergo during the process?
>> Margot Shetterly: Personal
transformation over the course
of writing the book, honestly,
the biggest transformation is
that I am now a professional
writer.
[ Applause ]
I am a full-time writer.
You know, I've done a
lot of different things.
I was an investment banker and
worked in the internet industry.
And this is the best
job I've ever had.
I think it's amazing.
I'm working on a new book.
I'm very excited.
I've gotten to know
people like Donna.
And I've come to look at
history in a different way.
I have learned so much
about our country's history.
I feel like I've
gotten to know people
who have influenced the course
of history that have sort
of disappeared from view.
So that, for me, this thing of
being a writer and the privilege
of getting to do that as a
full-time job is phenomenal.
I'm very grateful for that.
>> Marie Arana: So Margot, can
you tell us about your book,
or will this hex
you if we ask you?
>> Margot Shetterly:
Yeah, no, it's not a hex.
I mean, the thing is, during the
research, which was, you know,
this wonderful time machine,
I got to visit people in 1943
and 1957, and, you know,
all this kind of thing,
I really felt like
that's what it was like.
And I just kept coming
across these stories,
these amazing stories of
people like Katherine Johnson
who were kind of
just doing their jobs
and making differences, and
we didn't know who they were.
Anyway, so there are-- I
decided if I got the chance
to write another book, you know,
I had the little file of stories
that I wanted to work
on, and there are--
and sort of the Hidden
Figures series, non-fiction,
as I've come to think of
it, but these stories,
African-American
protagonists, same time period,
because I'm really obsessed with
that time, from World War II,
or really from like
mid-30s through the 70s.
Totally obsessed with
that time period.
Who were sort of
real protagonists,
people who did interesting
things.
Anyway, so the next book
takes place in Baltimore,
and it has to do
with business people.
>> Marie Arana: Nice.
Very nice.
We look forward to that.
[ Applause ]
Very good.
Over here?
>> Yeah, hi.
This is a question for Donna.
Do you, did you ever consider
doing this as a documentary,
given that it was a non-fiction
book, and why or why not?
>> Donna Gigliotti: No, I didn't
consider doing it as a doc.
I thought that it would
have a wider audience
if it was a fictional
film, or a feature film,
but a doc would be interesting,
just because there are things
that we, you know, there's
specifics in the film
that we couldn't
really dive into.
Are you a documentary filmmaker?
[ Laughter ]
You missed an opportunity.
Commission that doc.
[ Laughter ]
>> Marie Arana: Anybody else?
We had a question
down here, I believe.
Okay.
>> Sorry if I missed it.
Can you tell me again
how you two met?
Can you remind us
of how you two met?
>> Donna Gigliotti:
How the two of us met?
>> Yeah.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
Oh, I called her up.
>> Margot Shetterly: In the
parking lot of the Food Lion.
>> Donna Gigliotti: In the
That was it.
I mean, genuinely, it
was, I read this proposal,
and I said to her agent, I
must speak with this woman.
And he gave me a phone
woman, and I dialed it.
>> Margot Shetterly: So through
the agents I guess really.
>> Donna Gigliotti: Right.
It was really through
the agents.
That's what it was.
But it's been a, you know, happy
story between us ever since.
>> Margot Shetterly:
Very happy story.
>> Marie Arana: Over here?
>> Hi, this question
is for Margot.
>> You're next, okay?
>> One thing that really
struck me was you talking
about your book being a love
letter to Hampton, Virginia.
I went to Tuskegee
University at HBCUs.
Our islands of excellence,
where we do see people who look
like us, where you do see
examples of black success,
and that makes such
a huge difference
when you go forth in the world.
I guess my question
is, HBCUs seem to be
on the decline in some ways now.
The towns that surround
them aren't doing as well.
Not as many students want to go.
And I'm wondering, what does
that mean for the future?
Where do the Katherine
Johnsons come from?
And where's the community
that's going to nurture them
and tell them that they can
do anything, especially given,
using your word, the
Zeitgeist of the time?
>> Margot Shetterly: I think
that's a great question.
I mean, my mom went
to Hampton University,
my dad went to Norfolk State.
All of these women were the
products of black colleges.
I was just driving around
Baltimore today doing research
for the book, and Morgan State
is there, and I think, you know,
there are new buildings
and, you know,
obviously there's
a lot of energy.
Coppin State, which is also
there, has less energy.
You know, I mean, it's sort of--
there are issues that are
facing many, many institutions
of higher education,
not just black colleges,
but a lot of the black colleges
are really feeling these issues.
And that was, I mean, I went
to the University of Virginia,
you know, so my parents went
to black colleges, I didn't,
and so doing this
research, it was a real,
just an amazing full
panoramic view of the support
and the excellence, the
concentration of talent,
particularly during
that time period.
And, you know, but I
think, for example,
Spellman is a tremendous success
story, you know, when you talk
about the intersection of
black colleges and STEM,
they're doing extremely well.
I think Spellman
College graduates,
or sends more black women
to STEM Ph.D. programs
than any other school
in the country.
I think that may be true.
You know, and I think this
is also an issue, you know,
women's colleges, which
was another huge feeder
for these jobs at NASA
and many other jobs.
So I think that is a really,
really great question.
And, you know, the HBCUs I
feel were another character
in this book, and
another, you know,
along with the black newspapers,
another hugely important
part of this legacy.
And, you know, and I consider
myself very much the beneficiary
and the recipient
of that legacy.
>> Marie Arana: No doubt.
Yeah. We have a question
here, I believe.
>> What did you feel like when
you wrote a book or a film?
>> Margot Shetterly: What did I
feel like when I wrote the book?
>> What did you feel like when
you wrote the book or the film?
>> Margot Shetterly:
What did I feel like?
Wow. No, this is a
really good question.
>> Marie Arana: Because
we all felt something
when we read the book.
>> Margot Shetterly: Well,
you know, I have to say,
the thing is it was really hard.
It was really, it was both
really, really enjoyable,
and just I loved the research,
and I loved the writing,
but it was really hard,
it was hard, it was hard.
And a lot of it was hard
because I wish I could get
up in the morning and write at
8:00 with a cup of coffee and,
you know, like Graham Greene
I guess supposedly did that,
and just sat down and write.
But you know what?
I waste the entire day.
And then I don't
really start writing
until it's like 11:30 at night.
And that's really painful.
>> Marie Arana: That's common.
That's common.
>> Margot Shetterly: I wish it
were different, but it's not.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
11:30 in the morning?
>> Margot Shetterly:
No, at night.
>> Donna Gigliotti: Oh.
[ Laughter ]
>> Margot Shetterly: The
most productive time is
from like 11:30 at night
until 4:00 in the morning.
That is a good time to work.
>> Marie Arana: I
agree with you.
I agree with you.
No, but people don't
realize, I think,
that a lot of the writing,
when you're writing a book,
it's up here, you're
thinking it,
and you can be doing
the laundry,
and you're still working
it through somehow.
And when you actually sit down,
you've already done
a lot of thinking.
So it's okay.
>> Margot Shetterly: Okay.
But the other thing that
I thought was I really,
I felt an obligation to really
get the stories of these women,
you know, right, because I
wasn't writing about myself,
I was writing about them.
And so I felt a tremendous
amount of pressure
to represent their stories
in a way that was fair.
>> Marie Arana: How
about their families?
Thank you for asking
that question,
because it prompts
this question.
How about their families?
How did they feel
when they saw the book
and when they saw the
movie and when, you know,
the families of these women?
Because it wasn't
just the women.
It was the families as well.
>> Donna Gigliotti: We
went down to Hampton
to show Katherine
Johnson the film,
which is really a
nerve-racking experience.
Because, you know, you have
her life in your hands,
which you're portraying.
And her two daughters
were with her.
And she gets around
principally in a wheelchair,
so we had rented out a
movie theater in Hampton,
and her daughters, and she
came and watched the film.
And, I mean, I was
in the back thinking,
I don't know, I don't know.
And then I heard snuffling and
there were a lot of hankies
that were being spread
among these three women.
And that's when I
knew we were okay.
And she came out, and both
of her daughters were
very moved by it.
And Katherine, again,
I think she's,
she's not an overly
effusive personality,
but she approved of it.
And that was a big deal.
>> Marie Arana: Yeah,
generous, actually,
when someone is recording
your life like that.
>> Donna Gigliotti: Exactly.
>> Marie Arana: Well, I want
to congratulate you, Margot,
and I want to congratulate
you, Donna.
You have done wonderful work
in bringing these stories to us
as an audience, as a public.
And we just want more
of these stories.
So keep it up.
[ Applause ]
You can find Margot out
there signing books,
and I hope you will
take the opportunity
to meet her and say hello.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you very much.
>> Margot Shetterly:
That was great.
>> Donna Gigliotti:
That was fun.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.